welcome back to las vegas now
nickelodeon's beloved animated series
the fairly oddparents that we were just
singing the theme song 2 ran for 16
years and now the series is back
combining live action and animation
jillian had the chance to talk with the
two original voice actors who reprise
their roles in the new paramount plus
streaming series the fairly oddparents
fairly odder
were those we're your fairy godparents
i grew up with the show so when i heard
that it was coming back i was really
excited to see how it's done let's talk
about it what can we expect for for this
new season it's the comeback season what
can we expect of the new season fairly
otter uh i i think that the the main
thing is that
there is a live action show
uh with our characters cosmo and wanda
who have not changed uh still be in
animated form so it's a new family it's
new circumstances uh but with a lot of
the same messages about being careful
what you wish for
and
family and connection and the fact that
it's okay to make mistakes hey you wanna
hit cancun this weekend broseph
tight just gotta clear it with the wife
first and you guys are so fun you can
just quickly get back into character
back into those voices so i gotta ask
even originally did those voices just
kind of come naturally to you or did you
have to work on them they're so perfect
together
oh thank you uh i had to work on mine
because it changed so much from the
original pilot episode to the uh
let's just say hi ditched then kind of
dose of tones of cosmo
and i tried to think of
how a lullaby would sound in my head
i want to be surrounded by animals on a
farm you'll learn to choose your wish
words more carefully in the future can
you guys just be my friends and do these
voices all the time i would be
entertained every day
and just as a final wrap up as we're
getting ready to see all of the episodes
drop what are you most looking forward
to this next generation seeing from the
show and what do you hope they take away
from it
oh gosh i hope they i hope they just
enjoy and appreciate the talent that's
on the screen and the work that's gone
into it these guys are great the the
live actors that the singing the dancing
the comedy the acting the physical
comedy they're really terrific and it's
a it's a brand new family same old cosmo
and wanda uh but a brand new family in
brand new circumstances and it's really
funny and i i just think it's
exceptionally well done
wanda get back here jorgen van strangle
makes us tour all of his bathrooms every
time sorry kids gotta poop
gotta poof
the fairly odd parents fairly otter is
streaming now exclusively on paramount
plus one of my favorites that is great
many families are finally making travel
plans again with covet mostly in the
decline spring break vacations are
rebounding up more than 130 percent from
a year ago jamie yucca is headed to the
nickelodeon themed resort in mexico a
partnership with our parent company
paramount global where families are
making up for lost time
[Music]